Oh
I think that the public image of of
hunter is best captured by by the the
fear and loathing character a
freeloading Las Vegas character which is
really all about drinking way too much
taking way too much you know many drugs
and just being out of control
I would describe honor Thompson as
complex he was brilliant he was
sometimes crazy he was focused he was
very ambitious he was given to just
eruptions of rage further you know small
provocations he was a complex man what I
described Hunter as a parent uninvolved
I would say and I think there's a few
reasons for that first you know he was
born in 1936 so when he's growing up
he didn't grow up and out in an in an
era when fathers were you know typically
heavily involved with raising the kids
so that was part of it and second
writing was always that was the most
important thing honor
you know family was was secondary for
sure
I don't think he didn't you know he
didn't love me and care about me but but
as far as being like a you know no I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna go out tonight
and see my friends I'm gonna stay home
and you know hang out with the kids and
make him dinner no that's not that was
not him I have been asked many times why
do I call him hunter and and I call my
mom sandy and that's just the way it
always was and I think it's because you
know when I was a baby and you know
parents or
referring to themselves for whatever
reason he was not going to be dad and I
don't think he wanted my mom to be mom
he wanted to be hunter so I think that's
what you know when you know little
babies like Hunter you know not dad
honor when he would have these these you
know outbursts of rage it was I mean the
primary thing was just yelling but I
mean he could really yell you have this
deep booming voice and I think the
scariest thing about about him when he
was angry is is he could be just savage
with his words he didn't you know he
didn't get physical or rarely his his
primary tool was was a to say something
really cutting and vicious and because
he was so smart and so perceptive he
knew exactly how to to really you know
just go right to the core of somebody so
that was the worst thing to see and then
you know he also threw things and he
didn't threw things at people but you
know throwing a plate of food against
the wall you know high speed that's
pretty damn scary I did and I think that
was his intent you know it was to make
us it was to make a point and to to make
it clear that he was in control and that
you know the thing to do was
for other people to recognize that and
submit that without that was the point
and it would it worked it worked it
worked with kids it worked with adults
it's very effective
I was absolutely afraid of him part of
it was I was afraid of the possibility
of him getting angry so if I had a
friend over you know in middle of the
day and Hunter slept these odd hours he
would sleep till like 4:00 or 5:00 in
the afternoon and then go to sleep that
you know I don't know two or three years
something five or six I don't know so
during the day he was asleep so there
was this mandate be quiet do not wake on
her up and there really wasn't like a or
else it was just implied it'll be a bad
thing you do not want to you know do not
wake the sleeping dragon you know and
then he would have these outbursts and
you know was yeah it was it just a
possibility of making him that angry was
was terrifying
you know to a little a little kid and he
was a he was a big guy and he was loud
and you know when it was anger he was
really scary so yeah yeah I was I was
definitely scared of him and what's
funny is that I mean he never hit me you
can't think that he really was like
verbally abusive he certainly was to
other people but it's funny that didn't
matter you know it was it was just a
possibility knowing that that he could
do that you know being afraid that he
would do it to me
when I think of hunter being angry the
event that stands out most clearly is
one night after my mom and he had been
arguing you know we're still there in
the house she called the police which
was something he just did not do she
called the police and they came and my
mom was trying to she's getting some
drawers of clothes from her room to take
outside put him in the car so we could
you know drive away and and he I
remember him grabbing you know grabbing
the drawer of clothes from her and you
know something like well you know you're
not going her with that and and it was
just such a just a cruel thing to do you
know just to to
for him to just in demand that obedience
and to exert so much control I just I
just you know I was like eleven years
old like five feet tall you know a
little scrawny kid and I just I just I I
lost it I just started screaming at it
and you know tried to try to hit him on
the you know cop grabbed me and you know
held me back and there wasn't but I was
I was a little kid it wasn't anything I
do but I just I was just I just couldn't
stay anymore though just so outraged it
at what a bastard he was and that really
did to set my perception of who he was
for you know for several years until I
was able to realize alright well that's
that's part of him it's part of him but
it's you know that's not all there's I
mean the single biggest issue was he was
watching those fights and and just how
he how he treated my mom and the two
years or so you know between when it
when that tension really erupted and
became visible to me - when my mom
decided to you know move out of the
house and start the divorce process and
then oddly that kind of started the
beginning of our reconciliation -
because now I no longer lived with them
and and I wanted a relationship with him
it was a complicated complicated time on
one hand I just you know at times I
hated him but he was also my father and
I wanted I wanted a relationship so he
would invite me out sometimes and I
gotten you know spend the night and
and we would begin to build that
relationship that we hadn't that we
never never had before and then it took
it took years and years of you know
going to visit him and then things would
blow up and you know be more anger and
tension and then try again and there
were blow ups over it could be tiny
things like once I was there and he
noticed that a book was missing from his
bookshelf and so he started getting
worked up and hinting that you know
maybe I had stolen his books and me I
mean that's just that's just like like
paranoid thinking you know and sometimes
I just I just get really angry and I'd
yell at him and and then you know cool
down and start again but I I'm just
really grateful that both of us kept
trying you know we didn't give up and as
I got older it got it got easier I was
able to have more distance it's a it's a
whole different thing when you can
choose to be there as opposed to you
know being in a house where you really
don't want to be but there's no way you
can go and knowing that I could if
things get weird I can just leave you
know I may have made it a lot easier and
he really for his part he really tried
to to moderate to suppress you know his
his his impulses when uh when I would
visit at least for you know a couple
days the nature of our reconciliation
was not it was not based in talking
about it
that was not that was not the kind of
guy he was that was certainly not not
his generation or his background you
know they kept that stuff to themselves
and I think by nature he was not a guy
to you know talk about talk about his
feelings or particularly wanting to know
how anybody else felt so was all
indirect what certainly made it
complicated because I come you know my
generation is more about hey you know
here's here's how I'm feeling let me let
me tell you about it and he just didn't
know what to do with that so it was
tended to be more more indirect I mean
one of the big things that I finally
realized his is that he would try to you
know show his loving concern he wouldn't
say it it would be things like as as I
was getting ready to you know leave you
know after staying there for a weekend
he'd say you know here's $200 you know
get some tires and at first I was like I
don't need tires what and then I I you
know with the help of some some friends
began to realize maybe this is what he's
doing is he's he's trying to to to say
he loves me and in this really indirect
way and when I started to consider that
it's like oh okay
okay I can it's like a different
language and that really helped a lot
once I could start to to look at what he
was doing and what he was saying in that
way like I need to translate it I am
positive he felt very guilty about
about how he how he was a father
I think hundred guilty about all kinds
of things and yeah I think he felt
guilty about about the divorce and about
his behavior and you know not being
around I mean one thing he would tell
his friends you know once I was an adult
he would he was so proud that I was like
you know had a had a regular job you
know and got married and that I was not
you know a drug addict or a felon or
like he was so surprised that I seemed
pretty normal and well-adjusted you know
in spite of spite of our family growing
up and and and yeah the you know the way
he behaved well my son will was born it
added something something new and and
good to our relationship part of it was
just seeing him holding this baby and I
would never have thought that Hunter
Thompson would be good with babies
but he really was I mean for short
periods you know you wouldn't like I
wouldn't like asking the babysit or
anything but he just held you know like
six-month-old baby just so gently and
you know really focused on him at that
lot it's amazing and it was also an
excuse to to to see him more often
he really Hunter really did have a
connection with my son you know again
not that it was you know that they would
go spend lots of time together but but
he really felt a bond there and it was
I think my son might took my son's birth
was another thing too to draw us closer
together it also helped me to understand
how fathers feel about their sons it
helped me to understand that there is
this unconditional love that a father
has
you know for for their child and it's
just it's not I mean it's unconditional
it's not because of anything it's
because because you know for me because
he's my son
well my son was going to be born the
question came up right you know what do
you want to be called and he was adamant
he was not gonna be grandpa you know
granddad none of that stuff I think
mostly just out of vanity he just didn't
want to that that confirmation that yes
you are 62 or you know like you know
you're officially old so he said he can
call me ace not grandpa nice hunter was
not happy about getting older I mean he
wrote many times that he was surprised
that he lived to be thirty and he never
expected to live to be 67 and I think
there are a lot of things he didn't like
about it there was you know he's really
some of his really good friends or dying
that was very difficult for him and he
was a he was a he was a vein of Fame and
you know and getting older is is tough
you know he was it wasn't he wasn't
quite as attractive to quite as many
younger women as he used to be you know
and the worst of it though I think was
just that the physical the physical
impact which was combination of the age
and also you know 50 years of drinking
and drugs really took us took his toll
on his body and it became hard from day
just to get around you know to be
independent mobile and that was
especially for Hunter who was who for
whom independence was so important and
that was intolerable to be dependent on
other people you know for for everything
was just intolerable so in the couple
days before hundred-eyed will and my
wife and I had gone up to see him and we
hadn't be able to see him for Christmas
but you normally went there for
Christmas so this was a you know our
post Christmas visit and there was
nothing nothing unusual about it we
drove up there and it appeared to be a
pretty normal yeah you know a normal
visit there was no indication that he
had something you know there's plenty of
his suicide that weekend that night
there was a altercation between his yeah
his wife his second wife at the time and
him
and she got upset he got upset they were
yelling but it didn't seem you know
especially no I mean that was stuff that
was kind of normal for her and then she
went to bed my wife and we'll were
asleep and then in a offhand way he said
you know hey you know you might want to
take take some of these silver cups or
this little silver jewelry box and I was
like loud okay okay and I didn't really
think much of it now in retrospect yeah
it makes sense he was he was definitely
he was definitely thinking it was a
possibility and he talked about suicide
for years and years so it wasn't that
wasn't a surprise and I suppose I should
have you know I should have have heard
what he was saying and thought well this
is this is kind of unusual what you know
what's going on here but I didn't and
went to bed and the next the next
morning it was a really nice morning his
wife had gone into you know the gym and
we were just all hanging out my life in
will and and Hunter and I he was in the
the the kitchen at his at his table
where he liked to you know we'll do
everything and it was just a really
low-key calm
feel my wife and we'll went off to do
some sledding on this nearby hill and it
was unusually calm but in a really nice
way and then I was in a bedroom doing
something and I heard this this loud
like crack or thump and I thought well
you know dude drop something did he
throw something didn't we think much of
it came out of the bedroom looked over
and he was sitting in this in the chair
at the counter was chin down on his
chest
and and he looked like he was asleep
well that's kind of odd you know called
his name he didn't respond then started
to started to get worried you know it's
like as he has a seizure what's what's
going on here it never occurred to me
that you know he had shot himself there
was no blood that I could see he just
looked like he was asleep and I walked
over to him and then I saw some blood
there were there there was very little
though and people think of you know here
that he shot himself they imagined be no
blood everywhere and thank God it was
nothing like that
very little blood and once I saw that
then it all then it all hit and
I'd say I panicked really and I had to
stop going through my head that I got
it's finally happened you know I've been
thinking about hunter dying you know
some day in the future and I figured it
would probably does you know be by
suicide but in a really abstract way
like sometime sometime in the distant
future you know I'm gonna get a call
that he's dead and he and he kill
himself but for that to all the sudden
become real right now it's happened he's
dead I just lost it I decided to write
the book because after after Hunter died
the coverage in the media really focused
on that that wild man persona the you
know the crazy crazy drug fiend and I
really I really had a problem with that
because it just neglected you know who
who he was and why why he was important
you know he wasn't important because he
was you know alcoholic drug fiend that's
it that's irrelevant really and so I was
trying to figure out what can i what can
I do and then the idea of a book came to
mind you know and then what seemed to
make sense was to explain who Hunter was
to me through Mike's you know the
experience of growing up with them and
how our relationship developed and I
didn't end my book to be a biography or
the last word on you know here's here's
a definitive Hunter Thompson but I it
was important to me to to show hey there
was there was there's more than hundred
Thompson than just this popular
conception